Digamos que tenemos la función f(x) = x⁶ - 3x⁵.
Ahora bien, si usamos sólo lo que sabemos sobre
derivadas, te invito a que encuentres el intervalo
o los intervalos donde esta función decrece. Pausa
el video e inténtalo. Bien, vamos a trabajar
juntos. Sabemos que una función decrece cuando
su derivada es negativa; otra forma de decirlo
es que una función decrece cuando f'(x) ˂ 0,
así que ¿cuál es f'(x)? Bueno, podemos encontrarla
utilizando las propiedades y las reglas de la
derivada que conocemos. Vamos a aplicar la regla
de la potencia en x⁶: traemos el 6 al frente,
o lo bajamos para multiplicarlo por
el coeficiente 1 que tenemos por aquí,
y nos quedan 6x⁵, le restamos 1 al exponente,
menos, y multiplicamos el 5 por el 3, -15x⁴,
restamos 1 a la quinta potencia. Bien, y queremos
encontrar en qué intervalos esta derivada es menor
que 0. Ahora, veamos cómo podemos simplificar un
poco esta expresión. Ambos términos son divisibles
entre x⁴ y también entre 3, así que factoricemos
3x⁴, que multiplica a, si factorizamos 3x⁴, aquí
nos quedaremos con 2x y por acá tendremos -5, y
todo esto tiene que ser menor que 0. En cualquier
intervalo que esto sea verdadero, tendremos un
intervalo decreciente. Ahora, ¿cómo conseguimos
que esto sea menor que 0? Bueno, si el producto de
dos cosas es menor que 0, entonces significa que
deben de tener signos distintos: uno debe de ser
positivo y el otro negativo, o viceversa. Entonces
tenemos dos situaciones: ya sea que o 3x⁴ ˃
0 y 2x - 5 ˂ 0, este es el primer escenario.
O -y utilizaremos un nuevo color-, o 3x⁴ ˂ 0
y 2x - 5 ˃ 0. De hecho trabajaremos primero el
segundo caso, porque ¿existe alguna situación
donde 3x⁴ ˂ 0? Si tomas cualquier número,
incluso si es negativo y lo elevas a la cuarta
potencia, el resultado será positivo, es decir,
no hay forma de que podamos obtener como
resultado una expresión negativa por aquí,
por lo tanto, es imposible obtener esta segunda
condición: no existe ninguna situación para algún
valor de x que haga que 3x⁴ ˂ 0, así que podemos
cancelar esta opción. Ahora, esta es nuestra mayor
esperanza. ¿Bajo qué condiciones se cumple que
3x⁴ ˃ 0? Bueno, si dividimos de ambos lados por
3 llegamos a: x⁴ ˃ 0, y si lo pensamos un poco
nos daremos cuenta de que esto es cierto para
cualquier valor de x distinto de 0, incluso
si tenemos un número negativo, por ejemplo,
-1 al elevarlo a la cuarta potencia nos dará 1
positivo, sólo 0 sería igual a 0 cuando lo elevas
a la cuarta potencia. Así que podemos decir que
esto será cierto para cualquier x distinta de 0,
es decir, diremos que x ≠ 0. Y, bueno, esta está
un poco más sencilla. Si sumamos 5 de ambos lados
obtenemos que: 2x debe de ser ˂ 5, y si dividimos
ambos lados entre 2 obtenemos que: x debe de ser
˂ 5/2. Tal vez estemos tentados a decir "Ok,
los intervalos que nos interesan son todas las
x menores que 5/2 pero que sean distintas de
0. Ahora, ¿este es el intervalo completo donde
la función decrece?" Bueno, pensemos en lo
que ocurre en x = 0. Vamos decreciendo en el
intervalo de -∞ hasta 0 y también
decrecemos de 0 a 5/2. Entonces si decrecemos
justo a la izquierda de 0 y decrecemos justo
a la derecha de 0, también decreceremos en
0. Así que tenemos algo interesante: a pesar de
que la derivada en x = 0 es igual a 0, seguirá
decreciendo allí. Así que el intervalo que nos
interesa, el intervalo donde la función decrece,
es simplemente x ˂ 5/2. Y podemos ver esto si
graficamos la función. La grafiqué en Desmos,
y podemos ver aquí que la función decrece desde
-∞, decrece, decrece a una tasa cada vez menor,
llegamos a 0, continúa decreciendo a la izquierda
de 0 y sigue decreciendo a la derecha de 0,
entonces, para cualquier valor de x a la izquierda
de 0 el valor de la función será mayor que f(0);
mientras que para x a la derecha de 0, el valor de
la función será menor que la función evaluada en
0. Por lo que, en realidad, decrece a través de 0,
a pesar de que la pendiente de la recta tangente
en 0 es 0, a pesar de que no es negativa,
y después sigue decreciendo. Por lo tanto,
decrece para todos los valores de
x ˂ 5/2, lo podemos ver por aquí.